le 76
CPAM de La Rochelle hier a grandi sur 7
rue du quartier Laval des rapides il
est dans sa maison d'enfance qui l'a
écrit sauver mon âme de ta fenêtre il a
été inspiré par tes voisins d'en face
oui oui j'étais rentré dans un dans un
insecte religieuse n'est-ce pas et puis
il y avait une station des fois dans
l'image de
Dieu devant la porte
à Laval
métro Henri-Bourassa je vais en mer
américain monsieur ok parce qu'il y a
quelque chose à faire
il est question de
la noyade et de l'Amérique française de
[Musique]
Henri ce texte surprise il y a écrit
Rhapsody lavalloises en pleine pandémie
et en parti pour ses enfants de mémoire
tu perds deux fois j'étais pas là c'est
jeune 2020 ans de ma fille Claude Claude
aller à 50 ans j'ai eu un enfant dans à
55 ans je vis avec un enfant aujourd'hui
je vois son enfance se construire devant
mes yeux et ça me ramener à la mienne
avant de quitter un nouveau Laval pour
Montréal Luc De Larochellière a laissé
son magnifique album concept à la
propriétaire de la maison où tout a
commencé merci beaucoup ça me fait drôle
de voir seul ça me fait
changer
[Musique]
oui c'est les prix mais Radio-Canada
Laval sur une maison qui sont presque
les mêmes